foreign
is on the line in Charlotte North
Carolina Aiden how can we help
yes thank you so I'll give you a little
back story
um first of all uh thank you so much for
what you guys have done um you've
changed my family tree wow uh back in
the day my dad started FPU I think 12
years ago and now they're doing amazing
um I am currently 16 years old
um and so still in school obviously
and my question is I have a job
opportunity that I could go take next
week if I wanted to and didn't know if
it's better to just simply drop out of
school start working get these next few
years in early and then later on get my
GED and go from there what's the job
it is uh so it's a stone manufacturing
company so like the fake stone that you
see on walls and stuff it's not really
fake it's a Concrete that's kind of
painted I guess yeah and they create
those those uh Stones is that a job that
puts you on a ladder to climb to where
you ultimately want to be my goodness
you're only 16 and I love that you're
thinking about this but where does this
put you long term if you were to go now
or two years from now
so yeah so it would give me
um just a head start that uh is what I'm
looking at it from um and yes I could
climb and you know there's definitely
opportunities for raises and bonuses no
I'm not asking about financial I know I
can hear you man you you are a 16 year
old kid who's got dollar signs rolling
around in your head and you're dead mom
done a great job by teaching about money
I get that I'm not talking about
financial because it's indisputable that
if you go if a 16 year old starts
working out you're ahead of every other
16 year old I get that I'm saying does
going in this job at a stone
manufacturer is that your dream is that
where you want to be
so not officially but it would get me
closer to where I want to be eventually
which is what
um I want to get into business of
business ownership and real estate okay
so first of all Aiden I love you man but
uh and I'm the guy if there was anybody
that ever
would say it's okay to drop out of high
school I'm the guy well I'm the girl
because me too oh it freaks parents out
I'm freaking people out right now I'm
not telling anybody to drop out of high
school but we would not drop out of high
school
unless we were making such a huge
strategic decision that you had to take
at the time and the reason I say that is
and by the way I think I think High
School like I'm the guy that goes 16 is
probably old enough let's let him
graduate I would reform and totally redo
the education system I'm not going to
get into that Aid and that's not why you
called I'm just saying I'm the guy
that would be most willing to give you
the advice to do it in this situation
I would not do it
and here's the reason you have the
financial education your mom and dad
have done a great job setting you up to
win your head is on right as far as
thinking about the future and finances
but we live in a world still where there
is a stigma and their stigma's on a lot
of stuff there shouldn't be stigmas but
there is a stigma on
the GED yeah there just is and in this
case the
uh return on this decision right you
hear about return on investment well I
like to talk about return on a decision
if I'm decided to do this
versus this I want to know yeah that
there's a huge positive return and I
don't think it's positive enough I'm I'm
guessing your Mom and Dad aren't really
thrilled about the idea either and the
job connection the job connections you
want to own your own business one day
and you want to get into real estate you
know what I think you ought to do Aiden
I think you ought to stay in school but
I think you need to get hooked up with a
real estate professional maybe a
developer maybe a builder maybe a
world-class real estate agent and do
everything you can with them if they'll
give you a part-time job doing grunt
work do that if they'll let you Shadow
them do that because if I know it's 16 a
Direction I want to go I want to get in
proximity and I'm going to give you an
early Christmas present it's the number
one best-selling book called The
Proximity principle which says Aiden in
order to do what Aiden wants to do he's
got to be around people that are doing
it and in places where it is happening
my good friend Jade knows this formula
she's used it it's simply this the right
people plus the right places equals
opportunity Jade absolutely I've seen it
I've seen it in full effect Ken and I
think that if Aiden kind of holds his
horses here and plays his cards right
like what you're saying uh I think he's
gonna see it yeah work for him too you
know he's he's got a lot of time he's
got a lot of time but I am so happy to
get a call from a 16 year old okay who's
thinking big Jade yeah he's got his head
on straight his parents see this is not
one of the whiners that we talked about
early on this this kid's got his head on
straight he's right he's willing and and
ready to work I love that I love that
man he's a young man
he's a young man you know and because
he's thinking big picture and I love
this but yeah uh here's the deal for for
young people listening
um and Jay you know you talked about you
live this when we make a decision
please look at it from every angle oh
yeah and it's not about getting ahead in
the now
the decision must be about getting ahead
in the next and he's thinking now and I
love this kid he's 16 but he's going
well I just make more money for two more
years well the negative of that decision
outweighs the positive of having more
money in his account you know uh there's
this teaching that I heard
um a while back I've heard it many times
it's called the 2020 approach and uh uh
back in Florida at our church this this
couple used to come Mac and Julie
Richard and their whole thing was
parenting and they used to teach 2020
parenting where it's parenting for the
the 20 minutes or 20 years and that
approach that's it that approach Works
in so many other ways when you're
thinking about career when you're
thinking about your money it's so
important to think about the 2020
approach am I making this decision
that's going to feel good for the next
20 minutes that's going to be convenient
for the next 20 minutes or am I thinking
about the next 20 years that's 20 20
thank you Mac and Julie Richard wow Lake
Hills Church she's Jade warshaw now you
know why I say she's fabulous I'm Ken
Coleman and this is the Ramsey Show
don't move